so you often hear from me when I do
value tainment episodes but I'm gonna do
something different today I'm gonna have
you hear from my wife yes my wife is
going to talk to you today on what it is
to be married to an entrepreneur
especially after the video that came out
a few weeks ago called 15 things you
should know before dating an
entrepreneur and so many wives message
and said Pat can you please make a
message on for the woman side so for the
partner side so we can hear it as I said
you know what why don't I just have my
wife do video and let her tell you now
one thing you need to know about my wife
is this while she shoots this video
she's nine months pregnant the baby's
doing three weeks we're on our third one
I met my wife she moved from Houston to
LA and when she moved to LA not knowing
anybody and her third year in business
and a financial industry she made 150
year on her own pen she worked hard
hardworking person then we met in the
business together five and a half years
that we went on our first date and then
the rest is history but I want her to
tell you her experience from her point
of view and her messages too I like how
she did it one message is to the person
that's with the entrepreneur married to
the entrepreneur so if I'm the
entrepreneur the wife's you know message
being directed to her how does to be
with the entrepreneur or regardless but
whoever is the entrepreneur and the
second part of our messages to the
actual entrepreneur here's what you need
to be doing if you want me to support
you I expect you to do this and I
thought it's a fantastic message it's a
good mix up for you to hear somebody
else give the message to use well so
with that being said here's my wife
Jennifer
Beth David hi my name is Jennifer BETT
David the wife of Patrick David for
value tainment a few weeks ago Patrick
came out with the video that was 15
things to know when you're dating an
entrepreneur so this is my response to
that actually was requested for me to do
video in response based on my experience
of dating an entrepreneur so these are
the 12 things to remember when you're
dating an entrepreneur so number one is
be patient I often find myself waiting
on Patrick and you know that's okay and
you know I've learned that I must be a
little bit flexible with my schedule or
with our schedules he's not always going
to be home
the exact time that he promised and it's
just because he's working you know he
might be on the conference call with
some of the top leaders in the company
strategizing their next move or you know
he's working on a major project that's
going to take the company to the next
level whatever it might be I know that
he's working and it's going to be to my
benefit as well trust me when we're
walking the streets of Paris or relying
on the beaches of Hawaii I'm not
complaining about waiting on him a
little bit so tip on this one is to
remember when they work late it's to
your benefit as well point number two is
don't argue in front of others have you
ever heard of the saying don't air your
dirty laundry out in front of others
what I'm talking about is don't fight or
argue in front of your friends be sure
that if you have a challenge or
something that you're having a
disagreement on have those kind of
conversations behind closed doors
because trust me it's gonna it's going
to be a lot better that way Patrick on
the other hand he has no problem at all
with me calling him out just as long
said just as long that it's privately
and you can do that as well you know
typically you want to call out your
partner but make sure that it's behind
closed doors and it's in the setting of
your your own your own home and it's not
in front of other people a little tip
here is if you're wrong admit it
trust me they're going to respect you
and trust you more in the long term a
book recommendation here is the book
love and respect because men typically
are driven by respect and women are
driven by love point number three is
there will be spontaneous moments
Patrick is the king of spontaneity I
remember when we were dating just for a
few months it was my birthday and he
called me up one day and said hey you
know meet me here in about thirty
minutes and of course I'm angry and
frustrated because it's my birthday you
know when she burped that you want to
get dressed up and look really nice and
so I didn't have time to do that and the
whole way that we were going to the
location that we were going I was upset
because I didn't have time to get ready
so sure enough he had planned this whole
surprise trip that we were going to go
on a cruise in the Long Beach marina and
we had a whole weekend planned at
Catalina it was a whole nice event and
weekend that he had planned for my
birthday and you know of course
initially I was upset because I didn't
get to you know get ready and dressed up
like I wanted to but I had time for
doing that once we got to the location
so just remember is there's going to be
those moments of spontaneity so the tip
on this one is always be ready and
appreciate the quality time together
point number four know there will be
peaks and valleys I don't necessarily
mean financially and in this sense but
although that could happen as well I
mean more in the mood of your partner
because there will be times for example
when your partner is going through
certain situations or challenges that
they're dealing with at work maybe you
know they're having certain situations
it's really burdening them or it's
really heavy on them and on their mind
they're thinking about it constantly
trying to find some sort of solution to
the challenge or how am I going to fix
this and how am I going to fix this
problem and so they may seem a little
bit distracted or maybe a lot distracted
at home so you may be thinking that it's
something that you've done that has made
them upset when that's not actually the
case at all and then there's going to be
the opposite situation where everything
is you know great and they feel like
they're on top of the world so what I
would suggest in my tip on this one is
just really clarify where the mood is
coming from point number five is commit
to personal development since your
entrepreneur is typically going to be
busy traveling the world or working very
much on their on their business what you
typically want to do is entertain
yourself or work on yourself by learning
new things they're actually going to
really like the fact that you're
enjoying yourself and you're improving
yourself so what I would like to say is
that work on building your own identity
and don't you know so they don't have to
feel like they need to entertain you and
so what I've done is I've typically have
taken on new things that I want to learn
every single year just those last few
years I learned how to ski we went to
ask that took ski lessons that was
awesome it was so much fun I started
reading more books but also reading more
books that he was reading as well so we
can be growing together I took some
poetry writing classes learned how to
cook some new things and just really
started to work on myself and improve
myself but also you know and enjoying
myself at the same time so tip on this
is do things that will build up your own
identity
point number six has spice up your
intimate life change up your routine a
bit it's normal to fall into a routine
typically when you know you and your
partner if I'm trying to find ways to
have an intimate time together but you
know I'd say get creative in your
personal life because you want to
prevent you or yourself from the
possibility of drifting towards
something else that maybe excites you
other than your partner and we know
we're all that typically will lead so we
won't don't want to go that direction so
tip I'd say in this particular point is
to make your personal life a priority
point number seven is don't try to
control them you know you were initially
attracted to this person because of who
they are so don't try to change them or
control them because prom I promise you
if that is the case and you're not okay
with this maybe this relationship is not
the one for you anyways so I'd say my
tip on this is let them do what they do
best you know they always say that the
fastest way to make an enemy is to try
to change them point number eight is
applaud their achievements and praise
them my husband is my hero but how often
do I tell him that I certainly admit
that I can do a much better job at
telling him how great he is and we all
could do a little bit better at praising
our partners so keep in mind even though
you think that they are the greatest
thing since like since sliced bread
we can do a much better job at telling
them that more often so my tip on that
this is to make it a habit to be
encouraging and if you're not someone
who's good at verbalizing write a note
and then I would say a book
recommendation on this one is the five
love languages point number nine is lead
the schedule we all know that
entrepreneurs make their own schedule
but what I mean by this is actually put
appointments in their schedule as though
you're booking an appointment to have a
date with your husband or your partner
so if there's important weekend getaways
or you know family dates that you've got
to make sure that he or she is a part of
just make sure that's in the schedule so
important tip on this one is if it's not
scheduled it's not going to happen
point number 10 is
know how to deal with the critics for
example when Patrick and I first started
dating we got a lot of negative feedback
from critics from friends you know from
family members you know people were like
you know are you sure you want to date
that guy do you know who that is do you
know how he is you know and there were
letters that came there were friends
that were just really doubting the fact
that we would be together his family
wasn't quite sure if he should be dating
me because I was in Middle Eastern but
you know we learned to kind of put
everyone else opinions to the side and
we just continued to move on with our
lives you know and I know when we first
started the company there were a lot of
people that Patrick helped out and did a
lot of really good things for that we're
talking smack about him you know at the
time we were losing so much sleep
because we were constantly worrying
about these kinds of things we even lost
our first baby to miscarriage just
because of all the stress that we were
dealing with at the time but what we've
learned to do is we've learned to
anticipate the negativity that comes
along with the territory as an
entrepreneur we all have our own set of
critics and just remember this tip is to
focus on what you can control point
number eleven is don't feed their anger
and their frustration now your
entrepreneur is going to have some times
when they're dealing with struggles with
maybe there are certain people at work
or there's family members that they're
having a challenge with what you want to
do is try to come from the perspective
of the other person maybe that they're
having this problem with and try to
strengthen the relationship versus
weakening the relationship you know they
may come home to you and say you know I
can't believe that this person did this
and you can kind of say you know um you
know I'm not really sure babies that's
what they were intending when they did
that you know so the tip on this I'd say
is be a uniter not a divider point
number 12 is learn about their business
and how you can help and be involved
immerse yourself into their business
environment and understand it because
obviously you love the person that
you're with and so you should learn how
to engage yourself into their passions
and into you know their dreams because
if you're
undermine anything that they're doing or
you're coming in in any negative way at
all only thing it's going to do is going
to create a natural divide and you
certainly don't want that so the tip
here is to be supportive and engage
yourself into their passions lastly I
want to share with you a few points that
are going to be focused towards my
entrepreneur as everything that I've
talked about so far has been for someone
who is dating the entrepreneur so these
next few things that I'm going to
discuss are just going to be to my
entrepreneurs so point number one is
that your partner must see results we've
got to go out there and we've got to
make money now I understand the struggle
but this does not go on forever so you
got to make money you got to get results
number two is work when you are away you
want to be productive not just busy you
know your partners are sacrificing time
away from you and from your family so
you better be working when you're gone
from home number three is don't lose
your partners trust this goes birth both
ways and it's actually the key to this
is to maintain it it's kind of like your
credit score you know there's things
that you can go out there are behaviors
that you can do that's going to increase
your credit score and then there's
things that you can do to decrease it so
such actions like bankruptcies and
defaults are going to be bigger hits to
your credit score then late payments but
both are going to affect you negatively
and then some in more drastic ways
number four is constantly hit your
milestones and have constant progress
number five is to involve me talk to me
tell me about your business because I
want to be included those are my points
I hope that you have gotten value and
enjoyed the content for more content and
videos please visit Patrick petty be
calm and don't forget to subscribe
you